there's a very interesting new poll
from the wall street journal about this
upcoming election and it's interesting
not because it says biden is ahead by
nine it's we have many polls that say
that and it may be true
if we uh see the margin of error biden
plus nine might really mean biden plus
two
that's nothing new here what's
interesting about this new poll
is that it breaks down trump versus
biden
along a number of different voting
groups and when you look at it when you
slice and dice the electorate you see
that donald trump is winning among
men barely 47-43 that's interesting
because republicans tend to win among
men by more than four points we'll talk
about that more
on friday trump is winning among white
voters
barely 49 to 47 and donald trump is
winning among people with high school
or less education by a huge margin
nearly 20 points trump is up 54-36
among what are colloquially called the
uneducated now
every other group every single other
group donald trump
is losing some examples include black
voters
biden's up 88 to 80 brutal people with
postgraduate degrees biden is up 65-28
people who are college graduates biden
is up 61-31
among women and among hispanic voters
biden has 57
support and importantly among
independents biden is up 24
49 to 25. now when you see this
you have to consider whether some of
these things are casual
are causal or correlated so for example
the more education you have the more
likely you are to vote
biden we see that right high school or
less biden has 36 support so
36 support if you have some college
biden has 47 support if you graduated
college
biden support goes up to 61 and if you
have a postgraduate degree
biden is up even higher to 67. i believe
this is causal i don't think this is
merely correlation donald trump's
campaign
has been objectively one of lying to
voters
about things he could never possibly do
as president and many people fell
for voting for trump that's the right
terminology not everybody but many
people did
more education makes you less likely to
vote for a candidate
like trump and i would argue for
republicans more broadly so in this case
if you want people
to vote for trump you actually benefit
from hurting education not funding
public schools not dealing with the
student lending crisis
so on and so forth so you really have to
look at this stuff and understand the
link to campaign strategy
and platforms there are ideologically
based positions that
politicians will take or parties will go
in the direction of
but there are also self-preservation
directions
are republicans against education
because some of them see it
as anti-religious indoctrination sure
yeah that exists among
some right-wing voters but a lot of
right-wing voters recognize that the
more educated people are the less likely
they are to vote for them and so that
that's really important to look at
now one last word of caution biden plus
nine
in this poll two and a half months
before the election
is exactly where hillary clinton was
in this poll two and a half months
before
the 2016 election that's all that needs
to be said
trust nothing other than your ability
to vote and to convince others to vote
that's it we are coming up on the david
pakman show's
15th anniversary on august 23rd
on that day we will be sending out to
everybody on our newsletter
a huge membership special the goal being
to have our best month
ever for new memberships this month
because it is our 15th anniversary
to be notified of that special on the
23rd
simply subscribe to my newsletter for
free
at davidpakman.com